new york giants almost made it to the
playoffs last year but didn't
far from a winning record trying to
build something in the right direction
joe judge better than i thought the team
would be in his first season as the head
coach daniel jones the franchise
quarterback that they hope becomes the
guy that the jury is still out is the
energy of three what are the areas that
you would identify miles as the biggest
spots where the giants need to improve
this year
honestly i feel like you could just put
a big umbrella over it and just say
offense i mean when you finish you know
31st in the league and points scored and
your 31st in the league in yards gained
you just you got to do something to
improve that offense and i think that
they will be better just from the return
of saquon barkley i mean that obviously
is going to have a
dramatic effect on the offense just
because of what he can do as a running
back and how special he is as a running
back but man i mean whether it's
improving a wide receiver you got to get
more production out of the tight end
spot i think as well
you just have so many different issues
that you probably have to address on
offense because they weren't bad on
defense i mean they weren't terrible
they finished in the top 10 i think in
points a lot so
there are pieces that i think you've got
on defense but offensively those guys
with jason garrett have really got to
figure it out because if you don't then
you're not going to win ball games
i think back to the two times the giants
have won the super bowl this century
2007-2011 what did they have they had a
great defensive line they had a great
offensive line that that that you know
it's not
nearly as sexy as the skill position
players but
that is where you lay the foundation for
your championship team and we've seen it
with the giants multiple times the
offensive line they need and i know it's
not easy you you never know how guys are
going to pan out sometimes guys work
sometimes they don't sometimes you spend
a lot of money on a guy in free agency
and he plays well sometimes he doesn't
but
that's where they need to keep focusing
on improving the team they've got saquon
barkley they've got the quarterback that
they believe in offensive and defensive
lines the better those get the better
the giants will be and they're fortunate
to be in the worst division in football
where the path to the postseason isn't
nearly as fraught as it would be
elsewhere all right give me a guy that
you see the giants adding this year
either via free agency or the draft or
trade
i think curtis samuel is somebody that
could maybe fit that mold and it's
because he was one of the last draft
picks from david gellman's class in 2017
that he got there in carolina right
before he was fired then over the summer
and now of course he is the general
manager of the new york giants another
guy that maybe should be thinking about
the seat being warm under him but
they've only had 15 wins since he's been
there but i think curtis samuel is the
kind of guy that can be a dynamic
offensive player in the right system you
saw last year you know he's taking some
snaps at running back there with the
panthers he's a good receiver especially
was good on third downs but they really
need somebody to come in and elevate
that offense a little bit and frankly i
think that the top tier wide receivers
you know your chris goblins of the world
kenny gallaudet allen robinson i don't
know that they're going to be available
they may get franchise tagged or if i'm
them i don't know how much i want to go
play for the giants unless they are
offering me a ton of money so i think
curtis samuels one of those guys that
could be in maybe that second tier that
you convince yourself into saying yeah
he's a really good wide receiver and he
can help us mike
i think somebody is going to look at aj
green and say
why not why why can't we get him back to
who he was he ended the league in 2011
you know if he's healthy he can be very
productive last year it was strange
there were a lot of balls thrown his way
but only 45
completion rate for all of his targets
he had over 100 targets last year with
the cincinnati bengals but as the giants
and i know this contradicts what i said
earlier but you've got other means for
improving your offense and defensive
line i think that aj green could be a
value signing in free agency the money's
not going to be there it's not going to
be the kind of contract that other free
agent receivers will be getting and who
knows how much is going to be available
to them with so many
young receivers coming up through the
draft every year because all those seven
on seven camps the quarterbacks are
getting the reps the receivers are
getting the reps and better receivers
are coming in all the time it's becoming
like the running back position you don't
have to pay a ton of money for a veteran
receiver just go draft a guy just draft
a guy but i think they can get a good
deal with aj green and maybe he can add
something to that offense by way of
experience leadership maturity i'm kind
of intrigued by that i'm intrigued by
a.j green gener generally but of all the
teams that we've been looking at this is
the first time it kind of stood out to
me that maybe that makes sense for aj
green this year all right give me a guy
that you think they're going to get rid
of
well i think it's going to be dalvin
tomlinson and i think that they would
probably like to keep him i mean he's a
solid young player on that defensive
line somebody that they picked previous
regime but somebody that the giants pick
in 2017 but i think that they're
probably only going to be able to keep
one of him or williams and especially if
they tag williams you're just tying up a
lot of money there on that defensive
line and donald tomlinson i think is
just somebody that's gonna be able to go
somewhere else be a guy who can stuff
the run do a good job with that also
maybe push the pocket from the middle a
little bit he did have three and a half
sacks last season so he's somebody i
think that probably can go elsewhere and
get paid more than he will if he sticks
with the giants mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports